[Music]
Anastasia I want you
back have dinner with me okay fine I
will have dinner with you because I'm
[Music]
hungry got to be quicker than that okay
are you happy I've never been
[Music]
happier he's changing I you
but
[Music]
what this
time no
rules no
punishments
and no more secrets just keep calling
your name until you come back
home I to
[Music]
call you know that girl
Christian do you think you're the first
woman he's tried to save
him it's not what he wants anymore
your boyfriend has a
reputation do you want to be
kept or have
respect if something were to happen to
you I could never forgive
myself tell me what you have that I
don't
until you come back home rated
[Music]
R